-You look great, buddy. Thanks so much for being here.
How does -- It's good to see your face.
-I know, actually not on a computer screen.
-In person. -Actually to feel you guys here.
To walk on with that music! [ Cheers and applause ]
-You feel the energy, right?
-Yeah, you can't do an interview on your show
without the Roots backing you up as you walk on.
It gives you confidence when you come out here.
-Yes. Exactly right. -You feel like you're somebody.
-Yeah, Zoom, go on, git! You know? Yeah.
-[ Laughter ] -How's the fam, by the way?
How's everybody doing? -Everybody's good.
-Yeah, I saw Maya is doing fantastic.
She's on "Stranger Things." -Yeah.
-Maya Hawke.
Did you always know she was going to be an actor?
-I knew from the time that she was about 4
that she was definitely going to be an artist.
Well, first of all, I don't want to hurt her feelings,
but she's not good at anything else, you know?
No, that's the joke in the family.
But you get this young person around photography, poetry,
music, acting, singing, painting, anything,
she excels and she loves it and she can --
She is destined for great things, for sure.
-Yeah, she can sing, too.
-Oh, she's got an album coming out.
Her music is phenomenal.
New season of "Stranger Things" is coming out.
So I'm not worried about her.
-No, no. Good, good. Good for you. Good.
You told me backstage how awesome it was --
You got a cool experience recently.
-I had the best experience
I've had on this planet breathing.
-Yeah. -Yeah.
I had some great times not breathing, but...
-That's a different story. We'll get into that next time.
-It took me by complete surprise.
My son is going to college, and he said,
"You know, I'm playing a gig this weekend."
"You're playing a gig?"
He's like, "Yeah, somebody's -- We're throwing together a band.
We're going to play a show at this bar."
And I was like, "Can I come?"
He's like, "Yeah, all right.
Just stand in the back. Don't be weird."
So it's like, "All right, cool, cool."
So I came, and not only did he blow the room away,
but his sister was there backing him up singing harmony.
Just -- You know, I mean, she's like a genuine rock god herself,
and she's there backing him up.
He's singing his own songs.
He's singing other people's songs.
He's rocking out.
And I stood in the back, and it was like reasons to live.
It's like reasons to go through a pandemic,
reasons to be a human being.
It doesn't get better than that.
-I'm so happy, buddy. I'm so happy for you.
[ Cheers and applause ] I can't wait.
-It's just true. It's just true. -You were telling me that.
I want to talk about "Moon Knight" on Disney Plus,
but I also want to talk about --
You were just at South by Southwest.
-Yeah.
-With a really, really cool project.
-Yeah, I've got --
I've taken after Questlove and I made a documentary.
-That's right.
-Yeah, I'm following the best documentary
that has been made of all time, "Summer of Soul."
[ Cheers and applause ]
But, no, my pandemic project -- I've been making a documentary
about Paul Newman and Joanne Woodward.
-Wow. -And they --
For people that don't know, they have two 50-year careers,
you know, won every acting award.
They made meaningful, substantive art.
They gave away over half a billion dollars.
They raised a family.
They are two white people who were born with a lot
who did a lot with it.
You can be part of the solution.
And they were people that I think function
as kind of a north star
about what a meaningful life in the arts can look like.
They're really super-inspiring people.
-Legends. -Yeah, and so I've been working
on that documentary, and we just showed
the first chapter at South by Southwest.
-And that's going to air on CNN?
-On CNN in the summer.
-Yeah. Dude, congrats on that.
Paul Newman and Joanne, they are the greatest.
They do so much. [ Cheers and applause ]
I worked with them a little bit on our Ben & Jerry's flavor.
Our proceeds go to SeriousFun.
-Which is what Hole in the Wall used to be.
Paul started this camp for sick kids.
It's a beautiful thing.
A beautiful camp where they help children.
And now you're doing it. -Yeah.
-Because you're a stud. -No, come on, no.
I can't hold a candle to Paul Newman.
-It's a powerful thing to give people who don't have much hope,
to give them hope.
-If you go to that website and go check out --
google SeriousFun and what they do to --
-You got to do it. These kids are miracles.
-And he lets them raise hell. Unbelievable.
I want to talk about "Moon Knight,"
because everyone's so excited about this.
You, Oscar Isaac, and -- You said that Oscar Isaac
had a lot to do with you getting this part.
-Well, he did.
It's kind of like how you and I met in a lot of ways.
I mean -- -You remember that?
-Yeah, totally. But I digress. Okay.
It was during the pandemic. We're all masked up.
I go to get a cup of coffee. I'm actually with Maya.
And this guy with his mask on starts talking to me,
and I realize it's Oscar Isaac,
and he starts telling me about "Moon Knight."
And I'm like, "Cool. That sounds great."
He goes, "Would you be the bad guy?"
I'm like, "Sure." You know?
I said, you know, "Call Kevin Feige
and tell him to make me an offer."
And I'm telling you, by dinner,
I had the offer to be the bad guy.
There wasn't a script yet or anything,
but I just said yes because I liked Oscar.
He has a fire in his eyes, this guy.
When you meet an actor that has a real passion for a part --
And I knew this was a high dive off the diving board
to play a new superhero.
You know, people don't know Moon Knight,
and it's a really complicated character,
and he was gonna go for broke, and he was telling me about it.
I was like, "Mmm, I smell something great."
So I did it. All that off a cup of coffee.
-Yeah. With Marvel, how is that whole scene?
-Well, I've spent my life making independent movies
where you don't --
You know, if you're supposed to have a bus,
it quickly turns into, you know, "Well, we don't have a bus.
We have a..." -Bicycle.
-Yeah, we have a bicycle or a picture of a bus
going by you or something.
With Marvel, if you want a pyramid, you get three.
If you want a crane, you get five.
If you want a chopper, we got three.
-Yeah.
-Anything you can dream up, they make happen.
And so it's a little intimidating.
The first time I walked onto set,
they were the most magnificent sets I've ever seen.
You know, it was just -- and the extras
and huge cameras -- -They do it right.
-They do it right, man.
So it's only you that's going to mess it up.
-No, I'll never -- No, never, never, never. Yeah, exactly.
Oh, I thought you meant me. Sorry.
No, no, me. I meant me. No, you're not going to mess it up.
You're not even in the show, dude. You can relax.
-They didn't let me audition. They were like,
"We're good, man. We're totally fine.
Yeah, we have real actors."
"Sure, I can change my voice, make it deeper."
They go, "No, don't do that. Don't do that."
-That doesn't do it. -No, it didn't do it for me.
They go, "It's more of your face, Jimmy,
that we don't like."
Already -- The show's not even out yet,
and there are already fan theories about your character,
and I thought maybe you could either
debunk them or maybe hint -- -Oh-oh. All right. Here we go.
-This could actually get you in trouble.
-All right. I signed an NDA, but let's go.
-There's a fan theory
that the Hulk will appear in "Moon Knight."
-That would be cool, right? That would be cool.
Except I know Mark Ruffalo,
and I think if we were in the same show,
he would have at least texted me or something.
So I don't think that one's got a lot of legs.
[ Audience groans ] I know, I know.
Maybe in another one! -We didn't buy that.
-Oh. They think I'm being secretive.
...that whole Spider-Man stuff.
-That's right. Exactly. Yeah.
All right, there's a fan theory
that Blade will appear in "Moon Knight."
[ Audience oohs ]
Oh, stop. Now you're playing --
Now you're just playing with me.
Would you have got a text from Blade?
-Yeah, I don't know. I don't know.
I wish Blade was there. That would have been cool.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
You're good. The third one is the last one.
This is my favorite fan theory.
This one says, since not a lot is known about your character,
Arthur Harrow, some fans speculate
that Arthur Harrow is a decoy name
and you're actually playing the villain Dracula.
[ Audience ohhs ] -That is awesome!
[ Laughter ] I so want that to be true.
I mean, I -- Your expectation is so intense,
I want to say yes so bad.
I am Dracula.
-Oh, wow! This is unbelievable! -You heard it here first.
To hell with the lawyers! Dracula it is!
-All right. So, that -- Yeah.
-I want to be Dracula so bad. -Okay.
Marvel watches.
Yeah. So Dracula -- we can make this happen.
-Write in. Write in. -Write in, everybody.
We can make this work. [ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip. Thank you for doing that.
Here's Ethan Hawke and Oscar Isaac in "Moon Knight."
Take a look.
-We are here to make the Earth as much like heaven as possible.
Who'd like to go first?
♪♪
You're a brave man, offering your soul for judgment,
wanting to serve our goddess even before she awakes.
♪♪
I judge you in Ammit's name
with but a fraction of her power.
♪♪
This is the face of a good man!
-Yeah! Come on!
-I must warn you -- -Yes.
-Not all human beings are as lucky as that dude was.
There's a lot of people
that don't have the face of a good man.
-Yeah, exactly right.
-And those sinners meet their fate.
-They meet their fate. Ethan Hawke, everybody.
"Moon Knight" premieres March 30th on Disney Plus.
You want to conga?
You feel like conga'ing out of here?
Ethan, here.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]